nicolas vidal bonjour bonjour olivier
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver dans
la matinale de rtl france alors emmanuel
macron a donc pris la parole dans un
grand titre ou de presse féminine et
cela vous fait réagir ce matin nicolas
et oui olivier nous voilà le 1er juillet
une pétillante envier estivale a eu
raison de moi cette semaine pour l'édito
de cette matinale alors oui olivier je
vous le dis je suis allez parcourir le
site internet du magazine ul avec
beaucoup de délectation et d'
enthousiasme mais rassurez vous je vous
ferai grâce ce matin de passer en revue
les pertinent conseils de beauté je ne
recommanderais pas plus la tenue des
ailes pour flamber sur les plages cet
été apparemment d'ailleurs pas celle des
landes
je n'aimerais pas dans les détails
l'était psycho pour vivre en toute
liberté n'était sans contrainte même en
période de pré apocalypse du vaillant
d'état qui guette les français dès le 20
août ça nous promet d'ailleurs au
passage un bel été indien
alors pourquoi s'encanailler à lire nos
confrères du magazine elle
eh bien eh bien parce qu emmanuel macron
laurent cordes et vous l'avez dit un
long entretien entre les deux tours des
régionales sur la question de l'égalité
hommes femmes à l'occasion d'un forum où
l'avait dit ce mercredi à paris organisé
par onu femmes et j'ai pu dire quelques
extraits de nahla nice d'analystes
politiques pardon réduite au format
bikini du chef de l'état qui vaut quand
même le détour
parce qu'en peu de mots tout est dit
entre les dignes cher olivier alors que
dit emmanuel macron justement chez nos
confrères de l est qu est ce qui a
retenu votre attention
alors rentrons dans le vif du sujet
commençons par une déclaration d'
emmanuel macron tirer de cet entretien
je cite la tension n'est pas une
fatalité ici la première explication
c'est le kovy 19 sélections sont arrivés
à un moment où ce n'était pas le rythme
du pays et plus loin force est de
constater que les gens n'avaient pas du
tout la tête à cela fin de citation
donc notre cher président vous le dit
chers français
si vous n'êtes pas allés voter ce que
vous aviez les mains encore plein de gel
hydroalcoolique le masque intégral sous
les yeux et la bouche un test pcr dans
chaque narine et une seringue dans le
bras pour certains rien d'inquiétant
tout va bien on se voit en 2022
probablement que le pays sera à ce
moment là dans le bon rythme allez
savoir
cette déclaration a été piocher en plus
au milieu de nous
bien lima cciab verbe du rôle des femmes
dans la politique avec des phrases
creuses comme je cite plus des femmes
s'engagent plus des modèles se bâtissent
plus cet engagement prendre de la force
on ne voit pas trop ce club et cela veut
dire surtout après les régionales où la
différence entre xavier bertrand et une
valérie pécresse n'est pas visible tant
ils sont tous les deux dévoré par
l'ambition et le pouvoir
la seule chose qui les rapproche
finalement c'est de ne pas avoir atteint
être 17% des suffrages des électeurs
inscrits sur les listes pour faire bref
au ligue 1 sur 10 personnes rencontrées
dans les rues de leur région
moins de deux auront voté pour leur
candidature car là aussi la légitimité
politique a été mise en quarantaine et
le pass démocratique n'est toujours pas
obligatoire
en réalité en réalité manuel macro se
moque comme d'une guigne de l'abstention
historique dans ce pays et c'est
inquiétant
voyez le nombre de ministres des faits à
ces élections et qui sont toujours en
place ce matin
contrairement à la haye et règle
politique du ministre battu ministre
fichu olivier et cela pose les bases de
prochains mois difficile très difficile
pour une majorité de français olivier
mais nicolas qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire qu emmanuel macron porte finalement
peu d'intérêt à l'ab station à
l'abstention massive des régionales bien
la démocratie n'est toujours pas dans
l'agenda du chef de l'état qui accélère
sur les réformes alors que cette
abstention massive est aujourd'hui plus
que jamais un acte politique mais
emmanuel macron a préféré prendre les
commandes du bulldozer à réforme prêté
gracieusement par la commission
européenne dès lundi il a inauguré le
premier hub de la banque américaine jp
morgan à paris après avoir salué avec
xavier bertrand bras dessus bras dessous
l'installation du site d'une nouvelle
entreprise chinoise à doué puis il
manuel mâcon a reçu les patrons de
multinationales à versailles pour une
farce appelé shoes france désigné sur le
site de l'elysée écoutez bien comme une
chance pour les français étaient
présents cette coterie vip general
electric
arcelormittal hp samsung jpmorgan
netflix novartis siemens bayne
astrazeneca et heineken
il y en a d'autres voilà une liste des
grandes entreprises bien connues chez
olivier pour leur philanthropie qui
occupent l'olympe économie de cette
planète mais qui n'ont pas décidé d'être
spontanément les mystères
des français dans la décennie à venir il
n'y a qu'à voir le traitement infligé
récemment aux ouvriers français de
bridgestone de bosch et la liste des
langues
donc la promotion sur l'attractivité de
la france vendu par le gouvernement
cache en réalité une réalité bien plus
sinistre pour finir
olivier emmanuel macron n'a plus le
temps de faire dans la dentelle et de
cajoler les français il est pressé par
bruxelles je le dis tout le temps
d'appliquer les réformes structurelles
de privatiser le plus vite possible et
de baisser au maximum les dépenses
publiques donc réforme d'assurance
chômage et réforme des retraites
anne urgente contre le consentement
d'une majorité de français mais ils
devraient plutôt déchirer les directives
européennes qui ont par exemple ouvert
le service postal à la concurrence en 97
et qui a donné lieu rappelez-vous au
scandale de la distribution de la
propagande médiatique par adrexo même
darmanin le téméraire à l'a reconnu
alors emmanuel macron pour finir et le
gestionnaire en chef de l'entreprise
france qui prend soin de ne pas aller à
la machine à café pour annoncer les
réductions de coûts et les licenciements
en touillant son gobelet en plastique
avec le sourire arrogant d'un jeune
start peur prépubères olivier nicolas il
nous reste quelques secondes vous
l'évoquiez il ya une petite musique un
qu'on entend depuis quelques jours
concernant le report de l'âge de la
retraite
vous croyez que le gouvernement va y
aller ben vous savez je veux depuis un
certain temps le rectangle de retraites
et la réforme cardinal d' emmanuel
macron je le dis dans mon édito est
assez régulièrement
c'est aussi une volonté de l'union
européenne de bruxelles râpées ou le
semestre européen rappelez-vous
qu'ursula von der leyen est venue à
paris récemment donc va nouvelle macro
en fait ils d'élite obligé pour lui de
faire cet homme réforme des retraites
parce qu'on est dans la dépense publique
on est à la baisse de la dépense
publique absolue donc emmanuel macron
vous voyez il accélère moi je pensais
très naïvement qu'il n'aurait pas le
temps il ya eu le coville a quitté
jeunes ensuite les locaux vides 19
mais là il va essayer de faire
finalement passer une réforme a minima
vous le savez on va peut-être pas
toucher aux régimes spéciaux pourquoi
pour éviter l'explosion sociale
l'excédent populaire mais on va essayer
de
on était de remonter l'âge légal à 64
ans au moins faire se peut pour
finalement s'attirer les bonnes grâces
de la commission européenne
et ça chez lui il faut pas l'oublier
emmanuel macron il prend la présidence 1
de l'euro au 1er janvier 2022 donc vous
comprenez bien qu emmanuel macron ça
très fort jeudi en permanence c'est sa
réforme phare sa réforme cardinal c'est
comme ça qui fait passer la france sous
les fourches caudines du diktat
bruxellois donc je crois qu'il manuel
m'apprend il va accélérer d'ailleurs dès
aujourd'hui je crois que les
parlementaires se réunisse suite on me
décrit un exceptionnel
donc vous voyez bien le plan est là et
le bulldozer et élancée cher olivier
merci beaucoup
nicolas nicolas vidal votre édito à
retrouver bien évidemment sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis on se retrouve
jeudi prochain pour l'édito de la
matinale